la ville de montigny le bretonneux et
ses plus de 33000 habitants dont 23 1326
inscrits sur les listes électorales voit
s'affronter trois candidats ancien
directeur de cabinet de nicolas bour
michel laugier puis jean-luc ourgaud
laurent merckaert a quitté son poste le
31 décembre dernier pour se lancer comme
tête de liste de la majorité sortante
installé dans la ville depuis 2001 il
n'est membre d'aucun parti politique
mais de sensibilité centriste
nous avons l'intention bien sûr de
préserver ce à quoi les gens sont très
attachés dans la ville c'est à dire un
cadre de vie privilégié des services
extrêmement important et aussi dans la
relation qu'il peut y avoir entre les
habitants et leurs élus une connexion
permanente
déjà candidat en 2014 où il avait réussi
à mener une liste divers gauche mêlant
parti socialiste écologistes et extrême
gauche et finalement investi par le ps
qui lui a permis d'obtenir un siège
comme conseiller municipal d'opposition
lysiens gasc se relance dans la course
aux municipales il a quitté le parti
socialiste avec qui il a milité durant
15 ans et mène une liste écologiste avec
sa binôme kaoline ce chaos
on se présente un binôme tête de liste
et ça c'est important et dans tout à
notre action municipale l'idée c'est de
construire des binômes avec des gens qui
travaillent ensemble et et pas des
décisions ultracentralisée entre les
mains d'une personne ancien élu dans
l'essonne il a suivi la liste d'union de
la gauche de sandrine grand gang en 2008
et entre au conseil municipal de
l'opposition en 2010 en 2014 il ne
parvient pas à monter sa propre liste
mais c'est chose faite pour 2020 et
cette liste fermement ancré à gauche
rassemble plusieurs mouvance de la
gauche lui même et membre du parti de
gauche
nous avons choisi une autre approche qui
est donc que celle de ses trois grands
axes la démocratie la solidarité
l'écologie c'est une façon de présenter
qui je pense nous caractérise